>> Tucker: A CHINESE
VIROLOGIST IS IN HIDING TONIGHT
AFTER CRITICIZING THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT’S DUPLICITOUS
RESPONSE TO THE WILL ON
CORONAVIRUS.
HERE IS PART OF WHAT SHE SAID TO
FOX NEWS.
>> THE REASON I CAME TO U.S. IS
BECAUSE I DELIVER THE MESSAGE OF
COVID-19.
IF I TELL IT IN HONG KONG, THE
MOMENT I START TO TELL IT, I
WILL BE KILLED.
NO ONE WILL HEAR ME.
SO FOR THIS PURPOSE, I’D LIKE TO
GO TO U.S. AND TELL THE TRUTH OF
THE ORIGINS OF COVID-19 TO THE
WORLD.
SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND HOW
TERRIBLE, HOW DANGEROUS IT IS.
THIS IS NOTHING ABOUT POLITICS.
THIS IS ABOUT THE HUMANS IN THE
WORLD AND HOW THEY CAN SURVIVE.
>> Tucker: FOR TELLING THE
TRUTH, THE DOCTOR SAYS SHE WILL
BE QUOTE DISAPPEARED AND KILLED.
THIS IS THE GOVERNMENT, THE NBA,
AND SO MUCH OF CORPORATE
AMERICA, SO MUCH OF OUR
POLITICIANS SUCK UP TO, ONE WHO
MURDERS DOCTORS FOR TELLING THE
TRUTH.
THIS DOCTOR SAYS BEIJING IS
SUPPRESSING VITAL INFORMATION
ABOUT THE VIRUS.
>> THERE ARE MANY, MANY PATIENTS
THAT DON’T GET TREATMENT ON TIME
AND DIAGNOSIS ON TIME.
THERE IS NO PROTECTION FOR BOTH
DOCTORS AND THE PATIENT AND
COMMON PEOPLE.
AND ALSO THE GOVERNMENT DOESN’T
ALLOW PEOPLE TO RELEASE SUCH
INFORMATION.
HOSPITAL DOCTORS ARE SCARED BUT
THEY CANNOT TALK.
STAFF ARE SCARED.
I FEEL VERY DESPONDENT BUT I
KNOW THIS WILL HAPPEN BECAUSE I
KNOW THE CORRUPTION, THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION LIKE
W JOE TO CHINA GOVERNMENT, PARTY
GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: LET’S HOPE SHE GETS
A CHANCE TO SPEAK ON CNN.
DON’T BET ON IT.
GORDON CHANG IS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BOOK THE COMING COLLAPSE OF
CHINA.
GORDON, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
DO YOU BUY HER STORY?
>> I DO, TUCKER, BECAUSE SHE
TALKS ABOUT A CHANGE IN ATTITUDE
AND CALLINGS IN HONG KONG AS
WELL AS THE PEOPLE THAT SHE WAS
IN CONTACT WITH IN CHINA.
THAT OCCURRED ABOUT THE MIDDLE
OF JANUARY.
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT THE COVER-UP IN
CHINA.
SO THE TIMELINES MATCH UP, AND
THAT’S REALLY CRITICAL.
SO YES, I DO BELIEVE SHE’S NOT
ONLY COMPELLING.
SHE’S ALSO CREDIBLE.
>> Tucker: SO WHY WOULDN’T SHE
BE A PROMINENT VOICE IN THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT COVID-19?
I WORRY THAT SHE WILL NOT GET A
HEARING EXCEPT ON THIS CHANNEL.
>> WHILE, SHE CARRIES A MESSAGE
THAT IS GOING TO BE DISCORDANT
WITH WHAT WE HEAR ELSEWHERE
BECAUSE THIS HAS BECOME, LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP VERSUS EVERYBODY
ELSE, SO YOU HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE PROPAGATING CHINA’S
NARRATIVES IN THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE IT IS POLITICALLY
EXPEDIENT FOR THEM TO DO SO IN
THE SHORT TERM.
OF COURSE WE ARE IN A POLITICAL
SEASON.
BUT AS SHE SAYS, THIS IS NOT AN
ISSUE OF POLITICS, AND IT’S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE LISTEN TO WHAT
SHE SAYS BECAUSE IT DOES
CORROBORATE MUCH OF WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT WITH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AND CHINA WERE
DOING AND THAT CRITICAL JANUARY
PERIOD.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU THINK
-- LET ME JUST AGREE WITH YOU
EMPHATICALLY.
THIS ISN’T ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
IT’S NOT ABOUT POLITICS.
IT’S ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH
ISN’T SERVED WHEN GOVERNMENTS
LIE TO COVER THEIR OWN MISDEEDS
OR MISTAKES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE TRUTH IS
ABOUT THE ORIGIN OF THIS
DISEASE?
>> WE DON’T KNOW.
I MEAN, THERE’S TWO MAIN
THEORIES OF COURSE.
ONE OF THEM WAS THIS WAS DUE NOT
OF TRANSFERRING THE WILD FROM AN
ANIMAL TO HUMAN.
THE OTHER IS THAT IT WAS AN
ACCIDENTAL RELEASE FROM THE
WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY AND
I HAVE TO SAY THAT MY VIEW IS
THE LATTER ONE.
BECAUSE MOST DISEASES IN CHINA
ORIGINATE, AND THESE CORONAVIRUS
DISEASES ORIGINATE IN SOUTHERN
CHINA.
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE HAVE
ORIGINATING IN THE MIDDLE OF
CHINA WITHIN 20 MILES OF
CHINA’S P4 BIOSAFETY LAB.
IT’S EXTREMELY SUSPICIOUS.
WE KNOW THAT A CHINESE MAJOR
GENERAL WAS PUT IN CHARGE OF THE
LAB SOMETIME AROUND MARCH AND I
BELIEVE THAT HE CLEANED UP THE
LAB FROM THE WORLD KNOWING ANY
EVIDENCE OF WHAT WAS GOING ON.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE CHINESE
RESEARCHERS REACHED THE
CONCLUSION THAT YOU HAVE
REACHED, THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
THIS HAPPENED.
IS ANYBODY IN THE SO-CALLED
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY WORKING
TO FIND THE TRUTH AND WORKING TO
MAKE SURE IT DOESN’T HAPPEN
AGAIN?
THAT NOTHING LIKE THIS IS
UNLEASHED ON THE WORLD.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
COVERING UP FOR CHINA.
THEY HAVE NOW GOT TO RESEARCHERS
IN BEIJING TO PREPARE THE WAY
FOR A THIRD W.H.O. MISSION TO
CHINA.
BUT THEY ARE ONLY STARTING THIS
ZOO AND ARCTIC TRANSFER.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO WUHAN FROM
WHAT WE CAN TELL, NOT GOING TO
THE WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY.
SO REALLY IT’S AN ATTEMPT TO
BOLSTER CHINA’S NARRATIVE WHICH
WAS BUILT I THINK, THE NARRATIVE
WAS BUILT BY CHINA TO DIVERT
ATTENTION AWAY FROM WHAT IT WAS
DOING IN THE BIOSAFETY LAB.
>> Tucker: WHAT A TRAGEDY IF
THE PROPAGANDA WORKS AS IT’S